parts of Kashmir under lockdown
thousands of Indian troops monitored
checkpoints neighborhoods and squares
and more soldiers are arriving schools
and colleges are shut overnight
mobile internet is blocked politicians
are appealing for calm I appeal to the
people of the state Jammu Kashmir and
Ladakh that they should maintain peace
and have patience it is very necessary
we should not take any step that will
disturb peace in the region by Sunday
India put three prominent Kashmiri
politicians under house arrest two of
them former Chief Minister's it's also
banned public rallies this former leader
says he doesn't know what's in store the
uncertainty prevailed for much of the
week students from across the country in
Kashmir were packed into trains tourists
and pilgrims were ordered to leave the
Indian government says there are
intelligence reports about possible
attacks on the annual a monopoly match
but some think there could be something
larger in the works in terms of these
very dramatic moves such as ordering the
mandatory evacuations of tourists and
closing schools down putting local
leaders under house arrest to me that
suggests that something is much greater
as it play than a mere terrorist threat
there have been terror threats in
kashmir many times before and the Indian
authorities do not act like this so I
really think that there's something
broader at play it seems like India's
trying to head off possible unrest which
suggests that India could be planning to
make some sort of major moves such as
revoking cashmeres autonomous status
something that's unacceptable for many
here article 35 a and article 370 is our
basic constitutional right we have made
an agreement with India the basis of
these articles and now they are trying
to derail or revoke these articles this
is an injustice to us Kashmir is are not
going to tolerate this injustice
kashmiris one of the most militarized
regions in the world claimed by both
India and Pakistan over the past few
days tensions are high between the two
nuclear-powered neighbors as he traded
accusations of attacks on each other
Islamabad is accusing India of using
banned cluster bombs New Delhi says
Pakistan is sending fighters to staged
attacks across the border the valley is
on the edge amid fear and panic over how
little is known about what's to come
Priyanka Gupta al Jazeera